et on va prendre tout de suite la
direction de cette frontière avec notre
envoyé spécial sur place david khalifa
[Musique]
bonjour david alors la situation
s'envenime à la frontière comment est-ce
qu'on peut l'expliquer
et bien tout simplement car le nombre de
migrants
s'agrandit de jour en jour le nombre de
migrants affluent de plus en plus à
cette frontière en l'espace d'un jour il
aurait à doubler un selon les autorités
locales passant de 2000 à 4000 migrants
tout le long de cette frontière avec la
biélorussie le gouvernement polonais de
son côté avait anticipé cette situation
et a renforcé sa présence militaire ce
qui a créé des tensions et des violents
affrontements
ce qui s'est passé c'est que au
checkpoint de brousse guy 1 où il ya le
plus de migrants à cette frontière avec
la biélorussie est bien ce qui s'est
passé c'est que des migrants ont
commencé à jeter des pierres en
direction des forces de l'ordre des
forces polonaises les forces polonaises
ont répondu par des tirs de gaz
lacrymogènes et des canons à eau un
policier a été grièvement blessé au
crâne voilà c'est ce qui s'est passé
hier selon le ministère de la défense un
via son compte twitter c'est en tout cas
ce qu'avance à les autorités locales car
encore une fois pour nous journalistes
de ce côté de la frontière il est
impossible de faire un état des lieux en
tout cas de montrer ce qui se passe à
cette frontière avec la biélorussie
ainsi à par malheur nous nous rendons
dans ces zones dites d'état d'urgence et
bien nous nous faisons immédiatement
arrêté nous allons fait les frais
avant-hier avec mon confrère jordi
demory en tout cas cette situation s'est
apaisée hier dans l'après midi hier soir
également maire on ne nous sommes pas à
l'abri que ça recommence car plus les
migrants affluent à cette frontière plus
les tensions sont palpables et peuvent
donner lieu à ces affrontements à savoir
que toutes les informations sont données
aux gut parler les autorités locales et
devrait se décanter un d'ici le mois de
décembre car des zones spécifiques vont
être mises en place pour les médias les
médias polonais les médias étrangers est
d'ici le mois de décembre mais pour
l'instant interdiction informel de se
rendre dans cette zone a dit d'état
d'urgence pour rappel elle c'est un
ensemble de 183 communes qui sont fermés
une première depuis
1989 le ministère de l'intérieur
polonais n'a pas hésité a encore une
fois envoyé des messages à tous les
portables étrangers aux abords de cette
frontière avec la biélorussie avec des
directives est très clair un ne tentez
pas de traverser la pologne pour
atteindre l'allemagne épargner votre vie
épargne et votre santé en clair rester
chez vous rentrez chez vous des des
messages qui sont pour le moins assez
clair envers c'est un portable étrangers
le gouvernement polonais qui prend cette
crise migratoire avec beaucoup de de
sévérité puisqu'à partir du mois de
décembre comme vous le savez ils vont
commencer la construction d'un mur un
mur à qui elle devrait faire 180 km de
long et s'étendre sur plus de la moitié
de cette frontière avec la la
biélorussie coût total de ce mur 353 1
millions d'euros et puis comme je vous
le disais un il est très compliqué très
difficile pour tous les journalistes
étrangers présents à du côté de la
frontière polonaise polonaise de faire
son métier tout simplement car
interdiction formelle d'aller dans dans
ces zones dites est d'état d'urgence ça
devrait se décanter un comme comme vous
le disait et la situation ici est plus
que
déplorable pour ces migrants de chaque
côté de du côté de cette frontière qui
tente tant bien que mal de traverser la
frontière mais pour l'instant aucune
issue n'a été trouvée et la pologne
reste campé sur ses positions pour
rappel nous nous sommes à une
cinquantaine de kilomètres de là de la
frontière nous sommes à bialystok et
nous sommes obligés de faire un état des
lieux avec les informations que nous
donnent les autorités locales sans ça
impossible de faire son métier
correctement merci beaucoup david pour
toutes ces précisions david khalifa en
direct de pologne ce matin